till last week for his family to make
sure they were okay in Syria and now he
says now my parents called me here in
Paris to make sure I'm okay my name is a
youngster hall i am the founder and
director of this school association be a
clever the place is not just a school
where refugees come it's a place to meet
where refugees and asylum seekers come
of course to learn French but also as a
place to make friends we've had many
students who have been here for eight
years from Afghanistan mainly at the
very beginning and then very recently
from Syria Iraq and Libya
my name is muhammad atif ali one and
from Afghanistan i was born in kabul my
name mahmoud ahmed hachem i am artist
from Iraq painter and my name is melody
received I have the 27 years old I came
from Syria I was Oersted actually for
nine months from by security forces in
Syria and that's why what pushed me to
to leave actually so I get a lot of
problem i get two attacks and Iraq
because of of my artwork almost I lose
my leg because of this the problems and
the pressure we had in Afghanistan most
tremendous it was very difficult for us
I lost a brother was kidnapped and we
never knew what happened to him but we
did find his dead body when we arrived
in front it was a complete you can say
180 degrees change from the life we had
in Afghanistan we kind of felt liberated
as we know about France at the country
of human rights and freedom
when you arrive in the safer place you
try to delete all this try to live like
normal person without all this dark
memories about what's happened horrible
nightmares that they have seen all
around them families killed and just the
site all this blood violence cruelty and
so on so all of them have seen that and
they're just normal human beings and
then seeing it again revives your your
wounds we understand that the sorrow and
the grief that the French people live in
or feel one thing it should be always
clear to people is that the problem
isn't with the religion it's how people
use religion for political and
geopolitical gains for me like I am I am
Iraqi I am French and same moment I
accept to live here forever of course I
will I will come back and visit my
country if it's if it's possible but for
me this is this is my life here